[Musique]
Aguet Delon Johan le meunier exploite le
moulin à céréales qui fabrique de la
farine que Max transforme dans le pétrin
d'antan autant vous dire qu'ils ont dû
pas sur la planche
ce Meunier et ce boulanger vont nous
expliquer pourquoi le pain était au
centre de la table à l'époque médiévale
alors bienvenue
[Musique]
et si c'est fou fou
à des longs
alors parle-moi un petit peu du moulin
et comment tu es devenu meunier alors en
fait évidemment au départ des lions
c'est construire un château fort et puis
on avait envie de continuer l'aventure
et puis un jour au planning on me dit
bah c'est toi le meunier alors entre le
moment où on a construit le moulin et le
moment où j'ai commencé à sortir avec
mes collègues je suis pas tout seul
quelque chose qui ressemblait à de la
farine il y a eu quelques étapes quand
même et on fait vraiment du pain qu'on
partage avec les visiteurs la magie de
Guédelon on y va voilà allez je suis
ça c'est la rivière alors le bouton
marche-arrêt c'est là donc si tu veux
ben tu peux on peut ouvrir la vanne
ensemble
et c'est pas et c'est parti et il va se
mettre en route tout seul
et bien on va voir le labo alors c'est
ici qu'on va transformer les grains en
mouture et puis qui viendra de la farine
les grains tombent au milieu et quand on
ouvre la vanne comme on l'a fait tout à
l'heure bah ça fait tourner cette pierre
voilà c'est DJ meunier
ouais mettez l'ambiance vous
êtes avec alors les grands passent entre
les pierres et tu récupères la mouture
ici alors je dis pas encore la farine je
dis de la mouture il y a le son il y a
le germe donc il va falloir la buter
avec un blutoir alors en fait c'est
tamisé d'accord donc et le tamisage une
fois que tu as passé ça donc dans le
butoir ben ça va te donner ça donne
comme ça de la vraie farine ça c'est la
vraie farine après butoir mais qui c'est
qui bute un Guédon la tradition c'est
Max le talmelier c'est à dire notre
boulanger qui brute la mouture d'accord
ça se passe au château et bah je pense
qu'il faut que tu ailles le rencontrer
max bonjour écoute tu m'as demandé de la
farine du moulin
max le boulanger
dans la vie tu es un ancien boulanger à
la retraite boulanger pâtissier
boulanger quand on fait du pain au
Moyen-Âge il y a de la farine il y a de
l'eau il y a quoi d'autre le sel c'est
facultatif ça vaut très cher et ça peut
servir à faire tellement d'autres choses
que le sel on n'est pas donc c'est
farineo pourquoi le pain avait une place
centrale sur la table au Moyen-Âge bah
une tranche de pain déjà ça nourrissait
bien un saccalé et on peut le cuire
aussi à la poêle pas forcément aller à
chaque fois au banal si les gens du
village ne vont pas au four banal c'est
toute cette farine là qui vont récupérer
qui vont manger au lieu de la donner au
Seigneur et au banc
bienvenue dans Qui veut gagner du blé
première question quelle ici une
personne incapable de malveillance
quelqu'un de généreux bon comme des
vents
attention les mêmes questions pour
200000 deniers actes sans conséquence
grave cela ne coûte rien d'essayer ça
gagne pas de pain ça mange pas de pain
on accepte nos compétiteurs sont
redoutables la compétition est serré
dernière on peut le manger à tout moment
enfin dans ta gueule
[Musique]